Es ist wirklich nicht untertrieben zu sagen der größte anzunehmende unfall bei facebook hat stattgefunden der absolute supergau
Und das wirklich schlimme seit 2005 10 seit rund drei jahren ist es von facebook bekannt aber der konzern hat nichts effektives
Unternommen was passiert ist recherchen der new york times und des britischen guardian
zu haben ergeben gegen die nutzungsbedingungen des internetkonzerns
wurden private daten abgeschöpft und mit anderen daten kombiniert und offenbar zur gezielten beeinflussung
von facebook nutzern eingesetzt was genau passiert ist und für wen die daten gefällig sind jetzt ein klick zum zweiten fiction herzlich willkommen
Das hätte wirklich nicht passieren dürfen und was es noch schlimmer
macht facebook war dieses furchtbare datenleck bekannt und das unternehmen hat nichts effektives
Dagegen unternommen da ist es dem konzern scheinbar lieber keinen wirbel und schlechte pr
Zu haben als ein datenleck nachhaltig zu schließen es ist wirklich absolut grauenhaft und die folgen dazu
der reihe nach
Recherchiert haben die new york times und der britische guardian
hinter dem massenhaften
datenmissbrauch steckt die britische firma
cambridge
analytiker sie will einen algorithmus entwickelt
haben der in der lage ist aus ein paar likes auf facebook exakt geschlecht sexuelle
Orientierung und und das ist wichtig politische einstellung zu errechnen
Diesen algorithmus hat die firma auf die profile von
Millionen us wlan angewandt. Um die us-wahl gezielt zu beeinflussen
Sie arbeiteten dafür eng mit dem team und wer hätte sich da jetzt gewundert von donald trump zusammen und
Und jetzt können wir alle mal innehalten die firma hat in großbritannien die probe exit kampagne
unterstützt es liegt also nicht fern zu vermuten dass der algorithmus von cambridge analytiker bei der knappen entscheidung
der knappen backseat entscheidung das zünglein an der waage war wenn nicht sogar mehr eine absolute katastrophe
Wir würden dem unternehmen eine massive schädigung des euroraums verdanken die am ende wohl millionen kosten wird
Um wahlen zu beeinflussen sammelt cambridge analytiker daten um damit
Persönlichkeitsprofile anzulegen dass es absolut verboten damit lassen sich nutzer besonders gezielt, mit genau den richtigen
botschaften ansprechen um sie zu beeinflussen
Gegründet wurde die firma von hedgefonds mit der roboter einem glühenden trump unterstützer
Steven bällen der ehemalige chef berater und breitbart chefredakteur saß im aufsichtsrat
Trotz aufforderung von facebook hat die firma die abgeschöpften daten bisher nicht gelöscht so die recherche von
new york times unsere guardian dabei wurden die daten über die unterschiedlichsten methoden abgeerntet war die app
This is your social life getarnt als research app die vom psychologen genutzt wird mit der app gaben nutzer die
erlaubnis daten von facebook wie wohnort und likes abzugreifen
Die app sammelte aber offenbar darüber hinaus auf diesem weg auch die daten von facebook freunden
Und den kontakten dass es verboten
trotz aufforderung
So das ergebnis der recherche wurden die daten bisher nicht gelöscht facebook hat jetzt den account von strategic
communications aber tories inhaber von cambridge analytiker sowie die profile der mittäter alexandra kugeln und christoph meili
gesperrt sie hatten beide als psychologen für cambridge analytiker gearbeitet die
staatsanwaltschaft, des bundesstaates massachusetts nahm jetzt die ermittlung auf die britischen datenschutz behörden kündigten eine untersuchung von facebook an
Und ja wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema facebook
Datenleck und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp dann erfährt
er von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt über mich in der redaktion von krieg so mitmachen und mit themen zb vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und so direkt mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
das ist der direkte link und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter dafür auch drauf klicken
teslas sind datenkraken er ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran